une nouvelle scénographie un écran géant
4k une salle de 1000 places
le palais des congrès de versailles
souhaite reprendre vie les travaux ont
gardé le style architectural pensé par
pierre edouard lambert la ville il ya
investi 4 millions d'euros le nouveau
gestionnaire 2 millions il fallait faire
avant important notamment créé un
ascenseur monde change il fallait
insonorisé le bâtiment il fallait
reprendre un certain nombre de
dispositifs électriques mécaniques sur
un plan événementiel
ce qui est extraordinaire dans ce
bâtiment c'est qu'on a la capacité
d'utiliser les salles dans plein de
scénographie différentes comme on a des
volumes circulaire on peut faire des
scènes centrales cétacés modernes
on peut aussi travailler des procès n'y
sommes pour défier les modes mètres des
stands dans des configurations en étoile
pour des salons une inauguration presque
symbolique seuls 5% des événements
programmés en 2020 ont été maintenus
dans le monde de l'événementiel
après deux ans de fermeture le palais
des congrès s'est dévoilée ce jeudi 8
juillet en présence de bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez la
situation économique française
le retour à la normale s'accélère les
chiffres sont très bons les indicateurs
sont bien orientés sur l'investissement
sur la consommation sur le moral des
entrepreneurs
donc je pense simplement que nous tenons
le bon bout et des rendez vous sont déjà
programmées dès le mois d'octobre le
gestionnaire vis près de 190 événement
annuel
que ce soit des congrès des salons ou
encore des rendez vous culturels